et maintenant avec le temps avec le
temps va tout s'en va
voici jean d'ormesson
jean d'ormesson
on voulait pas se faire battre at elle
admis non j'en ai des gelées il peut pas
m'embrasser sur la bouche parce qu'il
est académicien
enfin je peux vous remplacez vous donnez
lui alors j'ai reçu un mail après votre
dernier passage dans l'émission un mail
de arnaud salomon qui a 25 ans et qui
habite à lille et qui dit juste pour
dire qu'en voyant jean d'ormesson
ça donne vraiment envie de devenir
académicien sosa je sais ça charmant
voilà alors il publie un livre qui
voulait appeler adieu donc voilà en fait
vous hésitez entre adieu les carottes
sont cuites il va faire est dans le sac
ouais ou et voilà le travail voilà le
travail c'est pas mal et finalement donc
ça s'appelle c'était bien et c'est chez
gallimard mesdames messieurs
voilà c'était bien alors c'est pas un
roman c'est pas des mémoires c'est pas
un essai c'est quoi un truc à ces intrus
qui planent à vous auriez dû le marquer
à la place le rsa truc ça on sait parce
que sinon c'est pas les mémoires
non on ne fait pas un essai par dont on
me dit de quoi parlez vous j'avais très
peur qu'on me dit j'ai de quoi parlez
vous non c'est très compliqué c'est en
fait une espèce de d'état des lieux est
vrai voilà comment comment ça va voilà
comment ça va alors pendant que
j'explique comment ça va j'explique
aussi aux lecteurs comment lui va voilà
à peu près alors le pitch finalement
c'est le rugby
le pitch à l'académie se voit je compte
sur vous pour que le mot pitch je rentre
dans le dictionnaire de langue française
nom alors je n'ai pas encore fait entre
à l'académie je les fais entrer chez
gallimard et je leur ai dit je vais vous
expliquer le pic pic et personne chez
gallimard savez ce que vous les lieux le
faire alors j'ai dû mais comment vous ne
l'écoutez par 10 100 1000 emplois
et à l'intention de ceux qui font les
études je leur ai même dit par exemple
quel est le pitch de phèdre le pitch de
fait c'est une dame est amoureuse de son
beau fils malheureusement le beau fils
est victime d'un accident de la
circulation voilà voilà le pitch précède
c'est quoi une [ __ ] je la recherche
le pitch l'ua cherche c'est un petit
gars on attend une baiser de sa mère de
l'asseoir dans la nuit et comme on ne
vient pas suffisamment à son gré il va
dans les bals pour se consoler voilà ou
alors le la recherche alors le pistolet
de bouquins 10 ans et ma vie bilan
globalement très positif
est ce que je peux apporter un bémol
tout ce qui est positif c'est pas ma vie
c'est la wii c'est la vie ma vie elle
aurait pu être mieux
je serai muet je serai gilles je serai
aragon
je serai extrêmement satisfaits n'étant
pas un bon restant pas chateaubriand
n'étant pas gilles je suis un peu
mélancolique mais ce qui est bien c'est
la vie c'est la vie c'est la vie
en tous les cas ça donne le goût là
c'était bien alors en tous les cas vous
n'avez jamais eu besoin de psy voir non
vous avez survécu à la psychanalyse au
nouveau roman vous avez vécu à jean paul
sartre
ah ça c'est pas mal quand même non bah
oui il y en a qui ont laissé des plumes
alors il ya une autre façon de pitch est
votre livre j'en sais il ya deux grandes
interrogations dans la vie l'une au
début c'est que faire et l'autre c'est à
la fin qu'ai-je fait c'est une façon de
le raconter aussi
alors écoutez je vois qui est ici il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont 20 ans et si je
vous dois quelque chose thierry et je
dois beaucoup
c'est que probablement vous m'avez
fournit des lecteurs plus jeune que ce
que j'avais
quand j'écrivais au plaisir de dieu
j'avais sûrement des lecteurs que j'aime
beaucoup mais qui était sûrement
beaucoup plus âgés et peut-être que les
gens qui lui
attends sont un peu plus jeunes grâce en
partie à ces moyens aussi venir sans
faire de fausse modestie
c'est vrai que cette émission est
beaucoup regardé par les jeunes et
qu'elle vende élite ce temps j'avais
maintenant vous savez eh bien je
trouvais ça très dur
vraiment je trouvais ça très gaie et
pourtant j'avais des avantages énormes à
20 ans j'étais fonctionnaire
j'étais entré à l'école normale j'étais
payé ma carrière était engagé bon en
plus quand j'avais 20 ans je crois que
le taux de chômage était de 0,4 pour
cent c'est à dire que ce qu'on voulait
faire on trouve et où il ya métier vous
trouviez et bien malgré ça j'ai trouvé
ça très dur d'avoir 20 ans il y avait
une phrase célèbre de nos agents vous
connaissez je me permettrai à personne
deguire que 20 ans et le plus bel âge de
la vie eh bien c'était vrai montant
alors je vous jure que je ne cherche pas
à ces anonymes hadji oui mais je trouve
que les gens qui ont 20 ans aujourd'hui
ont vraiment beaucoup de courage parce
qu'ils sont très gais s'en remettraient
est très très confiant et je trouve ça
épatant
alors votre précédent livre gens simples
et voyez comme en danse et ça commençait
déjà autour du cercueil d'un ami à c'est
déjà un peu vous comptez vous savez vous
savez c'est vrai et vous savez
quelquefois on me dit alors qu'est ce
que tu penses de ton livre et je dis je
ne sais pas je n'ai encore vu personne
et c'est les gens qui lisent les livres
qui m'apprennent et qui tout à coup
c'est vrai ce livre site où ni quand
même beaucoup autour de de la maison
'l'annonce d'année par le nonce de ma
mort est très mature et oui mais enfin
bon moi je suis et moi je suis si vous
faites ça pour qu'on vous il reste avec
nous et c'est vrai regardez moi ces
volpone ses vols peuvent enfin le lift
précédents s'étaient déjà l'enterrement
et je sais pas peut-être que
quelques-uns d'entre vous se souviennent
d'un livre qui s'appelait la loisne le
maire et je mourrai à la première phase
alors évidemment c'est un problème qui
m'a un peu fait pour conjurer le sort je
suis sur moi c'est peut-être aussi
certaines vous avez honte traitant
j'apparais beaucoup comme lui fais de
champion un peu benêt du bonheur crétins
qui trouve que tout va bien
il ya aussi sûrement une grande
mélancolie dans et dans mes livres le
puck début mai une mélancolie à ses
gains jeudi à tous les gens qui sont ici
profiter de jean d'ormesson parce
qu'elle n'a pas beaucoup des comme ça
moi j'en profite au maximum si je
pouvais l'avoir cinq plaintes
enregistrées l'accent soit pas d'abord
merci thierry je voudrais ajouter que
profiter de moi que vous l'avez peu pour
si longtemps
et ensuite et il joue et vous demandez
est ce que je pourrais avoir ici un rôle
serviette
oui mes pantoufles mais attendez parce
que quand j'arrive là évidemment j'ai
l'impression de mieux chez moi je vais
écouter l'andante âge non que je voulais
remplacer baffie vous pouvez bien alors
le contenu du bouquin alors il ya cette
phrase vous vous dites
la vie c'est les livres les femmes et
les bains de mer et gaston gallimard lui
disait le danemark les femmes et alors
si c'est quand même un jour il répond
c'est pas tant vrai alors c'est pas tant
les bannières bon vous voyez ce que
c'est ça veut dire pas seulement lehman
maire est bon les courses en voiture
l'italie les îles grecques
les voyages voilà voilà
bon et puis les femmes alors ça c'est
bien parce que on m'a souvent dit à la
télévision pas de tunnel pas que tu
n'aimes sur les femmes
on n'en parle pas pour le moment il n'y
en a pas alors et les livres alors on
peut en parler
on parle évidemment des thèmes qui sont
des thèmes or mais sonia come on come on
dira bientôt le privilège de la
naissance le sens de l'histoire vous
parler du big bang
c'est très très riche si les thèmes
souvent abordés mais cette fois c'est
vrai qu'il ya une petite mélancolie ya
quelque chose d'un petit peu comme ça
quoi
les lions de cristal le thème de la
naissance j'ai pensé qu'au fond bon gta
iv ou est-ce que j'ai été élu mais j'ai
été levé leurs achats tôt bah oui eh ben
c'est mon trotskisme amouya les gens qui
ont un passé trop ce qu'ils vont pas
très bien pourquoi les emmerder avec ça
éternellement
et ben moi non plus on va pas m'emmerder
entendu j'ai été élevé à château à tout
à fait trotskisme il en reste quelque
chose du château il en reste quelque
chose aussi
mais on essaie d'oublier tout ça voilà
dans le bilan ou fait finalement de la
vie d'une certaine façon j'en sais
comment s'est guère pu sans parfum qu'on
arrive en quoi un
non alors si c'était à refaire si
c'était à refaire je ne le referais pas
1 non franchement j'ai trouvé ça épatant
j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé la vie et si
un bon génie ou un mauvais génie n'diaye
voilà tu peux recommencer je crois pas
que je recommencerai est finalement plus
donc la messe est dite quoi la même si
ça aurait été possible mais c'est le
mans s'est vite la messe est dite
alors qu'est-ce que vous changeriez si
votre vie était à refaire imaginons vous
acceptiez de la faire vous changeriez
quoi vous voyez les mêmes les mêmes
folies des mêmes terrains au oui je
cachais peut-être de rencontrer un peu
plus tôt façon de survivre à votre mort
parce que vous allez rester dans la
postérité non la postérité
oui j'y croyais alors vous savez j'y
crois plus aux abords je pense que la
postérité il fasse est une idée de
l'avenir
eh bien je crois que cette idée de
l'avenir appartient au passé
vous savez pourquoi un peu à cause de
vous un peu à cause de la télévision la
télévision est une formidable machine à
éclairer mais la télévision est aussi
une machine appuyé quand on ne passe
plus à la télévision
les autres passent et tout ça fait que
on est balayé et c'est très difficile je
crois que tenir
peut on restera dans la postérité avec
toute cette masse d'informations d'image
d'événements qui roule sur le monde
c'était facile autant de flaubert ou
jeanne briand ne fera auprès des aînés
ruraux m'asseoir t
moi je vous prie les émissions mais je
vous promets la tête du mal on dira
qu'ils cessent dallas voilà vous êtes
très fort si vous avez fait arrive à
faire ce bouquin là sans parler de vous
en fait oui alors vous savez j'ai eu un
malin il ya une différence à gleason
politique c'est que eux disent toujours
nous sommes transparents oui moi je suis
par trans pas du tout non à lui mais à
une époque où votre ami jean marie
rouart raconte ses coucheries à
montparnasse g c'est terrible derrière
oui alors si vous abandonnez un petit
peu l'idée vous d'aller un peu plus loin
dans les confidences alors croire dit
tout moi je n'ai pas grand chose non
mais d'ailleurs quand on relit
lysergique quand on relit les articles
ont été écrits sur vous on s'aperçoit
vite toujours métiers terriblement des
journalistes parce que vous laissait
rien paraître
vous devez vous méfier des biographes
parce qu'une fois que vous serez plus là
les mecs ils vont fouiller dans vos
papiers puissent avoir une étude insee
run away une idée depuis six mois et
demi au graphique mois et qu'on cherche
dans ma vie ça mais pouvant j'aime à me
contre chaque patronne mois prévient
même même si vous vous détruisez toutes
les lettres par exemple de femme c'est
une supposition que vous avez reçus on
va demander à ces femmes à qui vous en
avez écrit déconstruire évolue tout on
brûle tout en volutes ou mail avons en
fait un hommage
arte et c'est tout riendeau
d'accord alors bannie des choses qu'on
sait pas mais par exemple si je suis
très curieuse genre est ce que par
exemple sur rien est-ce que vous avez
déjà fait l'amour en costume
d'académicien par exemple non non jamais
elle transforme m mais même j'aurais pu
par exemple le faire sans habits d'un
camille siens mais un bicorne sur loire
non non est-ce que vous avez déjà
pratiqué des jeux érotiques avec l'épée
gens à être bon secours on va vous
expliquer sans arrêt que vous êtes au
bout du chemin gens nous on veut pas le
croire bien entendu on pense que ce
livre n'est destiné qu'à vous faire
aimer encore plus si c'est possible
et puis qui aura après alors encore
plein d'autres 1 c'était bien c'était
vraiment bien c'était vraiment super
bien mais quand même pour conjurer le
sort on va passer à votre oraison
funèbre est patent voici dieudonné